i like having
started before i could remember i knew i
was going to be
interested in stocks the rest of my life
but probably at the time i was
you know eight or nine i used to keep
charts on all kinds of stocks when i was
that age my aunt gave me a a world
almanac so i'm
i memorized the population of all uh
cities of any real size
but i just like numbers my grandfather
had a grocery store and
i used to buy coca-cola from them in six
packs for a quarter and sell them for a
nickel each
i sold the saturday evening post
door-to-door i sold ladies home journal
i had all kinds of little ventures not
not all hugely successful i might have i
liked doing business early on
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself
for example communication skills i tell
the students that come that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that
if they just learn to communicate better
both in writing in person
they increase their value at least 50
you have to be able to get
forth your ideas and uh that's
relatively easy i did it myself
i would follow my passion i mean
whatever turned you on
i found i was lucky i found something
early that that turned me on but
but you don't want to take a job just
for the money
you don't want to take a job for an
organization that you really don't feel
good about or work for people that you
don't feel good about you
you really want to be excited when you
get out of bed every morning it won't
necessarily be the job that you have 10
years later
but you'll be learning so much as you go
along
have the right heroes i mean i've always
been lucky in that respect
you know if you the people you look up
to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life
and the one well i'll give you two
pieces of advice i invest as much in
myself
as you can i mean you're your own
biggest asset by far
you're gonna make mistakes in life i
mean there's no question about it
you don't want to make them on the big
decisions you know who you marry and
some things like that so there's no way
i'm going to make a lot of
business and investment decisions
without making some mistakes i may try
to minimize them
i i don't i don't dwell on them at all i
don't i don't look back
the triumphs in life are are partly
triumphs because you know that
everything isn't going to be a trials
and and
i i would never get too hung up on
mistakes i know a lot of people that
really agonize over them
and it just isn't worth it i mean
tomorrow's another day and you love it
forward
just go on to the next thing
i can certainly define happiness because
that's what that's what i am i mean i
get to do what i like to do every single
day of the year
i get to do it with people i like i tap
dance to work and
and it it it doesn't diminish it it's
it's tremendous fun
so success is
getting what you want and happiness is
wanting what you get well
i don't know which one applies in this
case but i
i do know that i i wouldn't be doing
anything else i mean
uh i do advise you you know when you go
out to work go
go to work for an organization that you
admire people you admire because it'll
it'll it'll turn you on
and you ought to be happy where you are
working
if i gave you a car and it'd be the only
car you'll get the rest of your life
you take care of it like you can't
believe then you scratch and fix that
moment you read the owner's manual you
keep a garage do all these things and
you get exactly one mind of one and one
body in this world
and and you can't start taking care of
it when you're 50 by that time you'll
rush it out if you haven't done anything
so you you should
just really make sure that you just
remember that you've just got one
minded body to get through life with
them did you do the most of it
if you get to be 65 or 70
and later and and the people that you
want to have love you actually do love
you
you're a success the best investment you
can make is in yourself
if you invest in yourself nobody can
take it away from
[Music]
you